OK, let's unpack this.
We've all heard it, probably all
said it at some point.
This should be the norm, you
know?
Oh.
Absolutely.
It just rolls off the tongue.
It does, doesn't it?
And often when we say it,
there's this conviction behind
it, like a silent assumption
that everyone you know deep down
must agree.
Yeah, it feels self-evident,
Obvious almost.
Exactly.
But if we actually put that
phrase, that seemingly harmless
phrase, under the microscope,
what does should be the norm
really mean?
Does it actually carry any
weight in the, you know, the
real world?
Or is it maybe a kind of blind
spot we all share?
That's really the big question
we're diving into today.
And what's so fascinating here,
I think, is how our own ideas,
our perceptions of what should
be, so often just collide head
on with the messy, sometimes,
let's be honest, brutal reality
of how society actually works,
how it changes.
We tend to project our own
beliefs, right our morals onto
everyone else, assuming they're
universal, or at least should
be.
Exactly.
But the way norms actually get
forged, well, it's usually a lot
more complicated, maybe less
polite, and definitely less
intuitive than we think.
Absolutely.
And that's the journey for
today.
We're drawing from this really
thought provoking piece that
just rips the cover off our
perceived shared truths.
It brings up this core idea,
maybe a bit challenging, but
super insightful.
The smarter you get, the rarer
your obvious truths actually
become.
Which is counterintuitive,
isn't?
It totally.
And crucially, the more
dangerous it is to just assume
those truths are universal.
So we're going to untax some
surprising, maybe uncomfortable
realities today.
About how norms are really made.
Yeah, why people clash so
fiercely over them, and maybe
the most striking bit, why
nobody ever really sees
themselves as the bad guy.
Never the villain in their own
movie.
Exactly.
So yeah, get ready to have some
assumptions, maybe gently shaken
up a bit.
Yeah, it's about looking past
what we think should happen
beyond our own sense of
rightness, and really trying to
grasp the deeper forces that
shape consensus, or often the
lack of it.
Right, so let's jump right into
this first part, The Mirage of
universal norms.
This is where the source
material just boom, grabs you.
It doesn't pull any punches at
all.
No, it really doesn't.
It comes right out and basically
dismisses.
Should be the norm as well.
Meaningless in the real world.
Which is a pretty bold claim,
right?
Meaningless.
It is bold and it's meant to be,
I think, to make a stop and
think, the piece argues.
It's not just wishful thinking.
It's fundamentally flawed
because it ignores, you know,
power dynamics.
How change actually happens, it
says, should usually come from
our own moral convictions, maybe
small groups, A wish for the
world to be a certain way.
Like if only everyone saw it
this way.
Precisely.
But the world, as the source
lays out, doesn't just bend to
wishes or moral statements.
It bends to what enough people
believe in strongly enough to
actually, well, to fight for.
Fight for it.
Yeah, to organize, to assert it,
and at the end of day to enforce
it, which kind of throws cold
water on the idea that if
something is right, it'll just
naturally win out.
So our conviction about what
should be it's often
disconnected from the the
mechanics of it all.
Very much so.
That's the argument.
Right.
It makes me think of like
wishing for rain when your crops
are drying up.
Your desire is real.
It's important, Maybe even
desperate.
Totally valid desire.
But the weather?
It doesn't care about your
wishes, right?
Follows its own rules.
Atmospheric pressure,
temperature, all that stuff.
Completely different system.
So saying something should be
the norm is maybe like that.
A noble desire, a deeply felt
moral thing perhaps, but it's
disconnected from how social
norms actually work and evolve.
The world doesn't just snap into
line with our desires, no matter
how righteous we feel.
Exactly.
And connecting that to the
bigger picture, it tells us
social change isn't just a
passive agreement.
It's not like you stayed a moral
truth and everyone goes, oh,
right you are and adopts it.
Yeah.
If only it weren't that easy.
Wouldn't that be nice?
Instead, the source really
hammers this point.
Norms get built through a much
rougher process.
Conflict, compromise, asserting
power, often just long hard
struggle.
So anyone trying to make a
change isn't just like making a
moral point.
They're actually stepping into
this complex, sometimes ugly
process, negotiation, struggle,
maybe even confrontation.
Yes, it's an active construction
job, sometimes adversarial.
Definitely not just a passive
unfolding of what seems good or
right.
Think about, you know, major
historical shifts.
Like civil rights or women's
suffrage?
Exactly.
None of those happen just
because the principles were
right.
They happened because people
organized.
They resisted.
They pushed hard against the
existing power structures for a
long, long time.
Right, and this is where it gets
honestly a bit unsettling, but
really interesting.
The source throws out the
statistic that just makes you
pause.
The 7080% one, yeah.
It suggests that maybe 70 to 80%
of any given society has
fundamentally different
definitions of what should be
the norm, even different ideas
about basic right and wrong.
Let that sink in 70 to 80%.
Seriously, if not many people
disagree on the fundamental, how
can any single should really be
called a norm, a universal norm?
It really makes you question how
often your own obvious truth is
actually obvious to, well,
almost anyone else.
Yeah.
Forget obvious, maybe it's not
even common.
And this raises that critical
question, how do these totally
opposed yet deeply held beliefs
even come about?
And why do they feel so
incredibly right, so
self-evident to the people
holding them?
Good question.
What does the source say about
that?
Well, it touches on things like,
you know, our brains may be
being wired to assume others
think like us.
Yeah, we project our own
framework outwards, and
historically societies haven't
really had genuine universal
agreement on ethics beyond maybe
the most basic survival stuff.
So consensus is maybe rarer than
we think.
Much rarer.
Often what looks like consensus
is more about power structures,
dominant stories, or just plain
inertia keeping things in place.
The source gives a really stark
example to show this divergent.
OK, let's hear it.
So take something like anti
racism, especially its modern
forms.
One side might see it as
absolutely basic morality, like
non negotiable, a fundamental
requirement for a decent
society.
Some of this should be accepted
by everyone, period.
OK, that's one perspective.
Pretty clear, but then you've
got the opposing view and
they're just as convinced
they're right.
The source describes how this
other side might see those same
anti racist movements or certain
aspects of them as Marxist,
maybe authoritarian, corrosive
to their way of life, their
traditions, their national
identity even.
Wow.
OK, so a totally different lens.
Completely.
They might even look at certain
groups the source mentions
Antifa as an example, and see
them not as justice fighters but
as something dangerous, drawing
parallels to, you know,
historical groups like the Red
Guard or even modern Brown
Shirt.
Seriously, that's strong
language.
Extremely strong, but from their
perspective the norms the anti
racists are pushing are seen as
subversive, anti democratic,
maybe anti American, A threat to
the very fabric of society as
they see it.
And what's really wild and kind
of chilling is the symmetry you
mentioned.
Exactly.
The source points this out very
clearly.
Both sides genuinely believe
they are the last defense
against tyranny.
Both are utterly convinced
they're saving the world.
From the other side, presumably.
Precisely.
And both are absolutely certain
the other side is one step away
from tearing everything down.
It's not just a policy
disagreement anymore.
No, it sounds like a clash of
realities.
Each side thinks the other is an
existential threat.
That's the core of it, a battle
over who defines reality, who
holds the moral high ground, and
what the future even looks like.
Which leads us perfectly into
this next section, the
righteousness trap.
Why no one thinks they're the
villain?
Yes, this is such a key insight.
It really is, the source
basically says.
Nobody, absolutely nobody,
thinks they're the bad guy.
Like ever.
It's almost a universal human
condition, isn't it?
I think so.
The person we see as the
villain, they look in the mirror
and they don't see a monster.
They see a hero, maybe brushing
their teeth, feeling good about
themselves, totally convinced
they're holding the line, doing
the right thing.
While everyone else is just
wrong or asleep at the wheel.
Yeah, or maybe even complicit in
the danger they see.
They're the ones fighting the
good fight in their own minds.
It's a profound self perception.
Every side, every person, every
group, they all have their own
story.
A story of righteousness, a
narrative that justifies their
actions, makes them feel noble,
necessary, correct.
And understanding that really
shifts how you view conflict,
doesn't it?
It's not just about logic or
opinions anymore.
Not at all.
It becomes about deeply
ingrained self preservation
identity.
People's beliefs are tangled up
with who they are, their
community, their values, their
whole sense of purpose.
You know, it makes me think of
something simple like driving.
You get cut off, right, and
you're instantly furious.
That guy's a maniac.
Happens all the time.
But from his perspective, maybe
he had to swerve to avoid
something you didn't see.
Maybe he's rushing to the
hospital.
Maybe he just messed up and
feels terrible.
He's not the villain in his
story.
Right.
We're sports fans.
Both sides always think the ref
was biased against them.
Always.
Even if the replay shows
something else entirely.
Exactly.
It's that deep conviction in
your own narrative, your own
side's rightness.
It makes it almost impossible to
challenge from the outside.
It's like a shield.
An incredibly powerful shield of
self justification.
And that's precisely why just
shouting you're wrong almost
never works.
Yeah, the source is really clear
on that.
It basically says it's useless
because.
Johnny and Becky with the same
conviction.
That's the quote.
That's it.
You're not having a logical
debate where facts rule.
You're in something deeper,
existential.
As the source puts it again very
powerfully, they're not debating
you, they're defending their
very existence.
Wow, defending their existence.
When someone feels their core
identity, their way of life,
their fundamental values are
under attack, reason often just
goes out the window.
It becomes about survival.
They're not trying to win an
argument, They're fighting to
survive as they see it.
OK, so for you listening right
now, think about a time you were
just absolutely certain you were
right.
Maybe arguing with family or at
work or about some big issue.
We've all been there.
How hard was it for anyone to
change your mind?
How did it feel when someone
just flat out told you that you
were wrong, especially if you
felt like your poor values were
on the line?
It's incredibly difficult, isn't
it, to shift when you're in that
mode.
Exactly.
And that feeling, it's not just
you, it's universal.
It's what fuels so many of these
conflicts.
Which brings us right to this
idea of the blind spot of moral
absolutism.
The source isn't just describing
A belief system here, It's
calling it a critical, even
dangerous assumption.
A trap?
What trap specifically?
The trap of thinking that your
version of right and wrong, your
moral code is just self-evident,
universally true.
Like it doesn't even need
explaining.
OK, assuming you're obvious, is
everyone's obvious?
Exactly, and the author argues
that is the core blind spot that
can just completely derail any
attempt at understanding or
communication in a world full of
different views.
So what does this mean for us
then?
It means if you're not careful,
really careful, your strongest
beliefs, the things you feel
most passionate about.
They can become your biggest
blind spot.
Ironically, yeah.
The source warns that the second
you forget how rare, how
specific your worldview actually
is, 2 really critical things
happen.
What are they?
First, you stopped really
listening.
Why bother if you already know
they're wrong or irrational,
right?
Makes sense you tune out.
And second, because you're not
listening, you lose the ability
to understand why the conflict
even exists.
You can't grasp the other side's
motives if you just assume they
don't get it, or worse, that
they're just plain evil.
You stop asking why and just
shout.
How dare they?
Precisely.
And this is where the source
brings back that statistic, that
reality check.
In the US, maybe only 20% of
people share your specific moral
framework, your exact shoulds.
Only 20%?
It's not a lot.
At all.
And globally it's even rarer,
maybe tiny depending on the
belief.
Now this doesn't mean your
truths aren't valuable.
The source actually argues their
rarity makes them precious,
unique, important to you.
OK, so.
Rarity equals preciousness.
But it also makes them fragile,
Yeah.
And the big picture, rare things
survive, the source says.
Not because they assume they'll
win, but because they understand
their position and they fight
for it.
So it's not about being passive,
but about being realistic and
active.
Exactly.
It's about active engagement,
knowing your beliefs are unique
and maybe vulnerable, not just
assuming everyone secretly
agrees with you.
And this leads to that idea of
impotent truths, which sounds
harsh but maybe realistic.
Yeah, it's a striking phrase,
the.
Source describes these as moral
statements that sound really
strong.
They feel righteous.
They make you feel good, Clear.
Morally superior, maybe.
Very affirming.
But without enough people
actually sharing that belief,
without collective power behind
them, they become what was the
quote?
Loud, righteous and powerless
against the tide.
Powerless against the tide.
Yeah, they might comfort you or
your group, but they don't
actually change the world.
They don't shift the big
currents.
They just echo in your own
bubble no matter how true they
feel.
And that highlights a really
crucial difference we often
miss.
The personal comfort we get from
a belief isn't the same thing as
its power to actually influence
a diverse society.
Right.
Feeling good isn't the same as
being effective.
Precisely.
A belief can be deeply
comforting, give you purpose,
but if hardly anyone else shares
it, it's ability to shape the
norm is tiny.
So for you, the listener, think
about how often you might just
assume others share your basic
moral starting point, especially
in tough conversations.
Yeah, we do that automatically,
don't we?
We do.
Recognizing this rarity that
your truths might be impotent in
the wider world.
It could change your whole
approach, maybe moving from
demanding agreement to thinking
more strategically.
How do I build bridges?
How do I actually advance this
view in a world that mostly
disagrees?
OK, so if those impotent truths
don't change the world, what
does?
This really pushes us into the
next section, the real
battlefield, a clash of Titans.
Yeah, this section uses some
powerful imagery.
It really does.
It cuts through any idea of
polite disagreement.
The source just states it
bluntly.
The world isn't Sunday school.
It's a clash of the Titans.
Wow, not Sunday school.
No, it paints this picture of
huge powerful forces smashing
against each other.
Forces that aren't going to be
swayed by a well reasoned
argument or a moral appeal.
It emphasizes that we're not
just talking about small policy
tweaks or misunderstandings you
can clear up with a chat.
These are deep, fundamental
clashes, fights over the entire
operating system of society, you
could say.
And importantly, the source
says, these sides, these Titans,
they've been building towards
this clash for decades.
This isn't new.
It's not a sudden flare up.
Right.
It's been simmering, These
tensions, these ideologies,
they've been growing, getting
stronger, shaping how people see
the world for generations.
It's like different rivers
carving deeper and deeper
channels heading for collision.
So it's not just about today's
policies.
It's generations of different
worldviews, different histories,
different visions for the
future, all finally meeting head
on.
Yeah, the source even names.
Names, doesn't it?
It talks about movements
sharpening their swords in the
dark.
That's another vivid image.
Very vivid, it mentions specific
forces like Christian
nationalism, identity politics,
populism and different strands
of Marxist theory.
These aren't just abstract ideas
then.
Not according to this source.
They're presented as active,
organized, often passionate
movements, each with its own
followers, its own text, its own
way of seeing the world, its own
emotional fuel.
And the source says generations
of narratives have shaped them,
giving them the force of myth.
Exactly.
Which means they're not just
intellectual positions you can
debate away.
They're woven into people's
identities, their history, how
they see themselves.
Take Christian nationalism, for
example.
The source analyzes it not just
as faith, but as a political
ideology.
Believing the nation should
reflect certain Christian
values.
Seeing current changes is wrong.
Wanting to restore a perceived
past.
Right and identity politics.
The source perspective suggests
it may be started as a fight for
rights, but sometimes shifts to
prioritizing group identity over
universal ideas, leading to
clashes over justice equity.
Who's the victim?
Populism.
Marxist theory.
Similar idea presented as
powerful world views, each with
its own story of what's wrong,
who's to blame, and a
compelling, maybe even
revolutionary vision for fixing
it.
So connecting this back, it's
not petty arguments, it's deeply
embedded belief systems
colliding, each with its own
origin story, its own
grievances, its own vision for
the future, and each absolutely
convinced it's right.
And when these forces, these
Titans, finally collide on that
real world battlefield, the
source says, they don't care
about your shoulds.
Ouch.
Yeah.
Doesn't matter what you think is
right or fair or ought to be.
Their main concerns are just
survival, asserting their truth,
and who gets to write the next
chapter.
That's the picture of pain,
which completely changes the
game.
It's not a debate about logic or
ethics within one shared system
anymore.
It's a raw struggle over
existence, power, the future
direction of society itself.
The stakes feel absolute to
those involved.
So for you listening, think
about current events through
this lens.
Are we just seeing arguments
about what should happen?
Or is it, like the source
suggests, something deeper?
A battle for survival, for the
future story, for who defines
reality?
Understanding it that way maybe
shifts things from just
frustration at the other side
being irrational to a clearer,
maybe more sobering view of
what's actually driving the
conflict.
High stakes, deep convictions on
all sides.
OK, so if it's a clash of Titans
on contested terrain, how do we
navigate that?
That brings us to the last part.
Understanding the terrain a path
forward, though maybe resolution
isn't the right word.
No, the source seems more
pragmatic than that.
It advises something like hold
your beliefs, fight for them,
but don't lie to yourself about
how universal they.
Are so stand firm, but be
realistic.
Exactly, They're not universal,
they never have been.
It's about being grounded, self
aware even while you're
advocating for your cause,
passionate but profoundly
realistic.
And that point about rarity?
Again, your truths might be
rare.
And that rarity makes them
precious, the source argues.
Unique, valuable, worth
protecting.
But also fragile.
But also fragile in the bigger
picture.
They need active defense
strategy understanding, not just
assuming they'll automatically
win because you think they're
right.
It's recognizing their unique
spot without assuming everyone
else is or should be on the same
page.
And the danger of forgetting
that rarity, of falling into
that moral absolutism trap.
That's where the source gives
that really stark warning.
The moment you forget that, you
risk becoming the villain in
someone else's story.
Wow, becoming the villain
yourself.
Yeah, and it uses that image
that really sticks with you.
You're there, heroically shaving
in your bathroom mirror, totally
convinced of your noble cause.
Feeling pretty good about
yourself?
While they're sharpening their
blades, while you're admiring
your reflection, maybe flexing,
they are marching, plotting,
believing just as fiercely as
you do with their own story,
where you are the problem.
That is quite an image, a real
cautionary tale.
It is about self-awareness and
conflict.
It pushes us to look beyond our
own heroic internal story and
see the external reality.
How are we perceived?
Why are their beliefs just as
strong to them?
Ignoring their view doesn't make
it go away.
Not at all.
It just blinds you to the actual
battlefield, the source
suggests.
If you miss that, you're not
just at a disadvantage, you're
fundamentally misunderstanding
the world and how these
conflicts work.
So the ultimate lesson here, the
big take away, seems to be the
battle isn't won by who feels
most righteous.
It's won by who understands the
terrain, yeah.
It's not about being the good
guy in your own movie or
shouting your shoulds the
loudest.
It's about really, truly
grasping the complex reality of
the situation you're in.
And understanding the terrain
means really digging in, often
uncomfortably.
What are the other narratives?
What truly motivates the other
side?
What are their fears, their
histories, their sense of
injustice, the power dynamics?
It's moving past just saying
they're wrong to understanding
why they believe what they
believe, exactly.
Engaging with the messy reality
of human belief in conflict,
recognizing that every powerful
movement, every deep belief
system, no matter how much you
disagree, has its own
compelling, often righteous
reasons for existing from its
perspective.
It takes some intellectual
humility.
So for you, the listener, the
encouragement is to look at
things, big conflicts, small
arguments, not just through the
lens of your own shoulds, but by
trying hard to understand the
whole terrain, all the different
beliefs, motives, fears.
It's tough because what feels
undeniably right to you might
feel totally wrong, even
oppressive, to someone else, and
they're just as convinced as you
are.
This perspective doesn't say
abandoned your beliefs, not at
all.
But maybe arm yourself with a
deeper understanding of the
world as it is, not just as you
wish it was.
So let's quickly recap the core
insights should be the norm,
often a comforting illusion
disconnected from how change
really happens.
Nobody thinks they're the
villain.
Everyone's the hero of their own
story.
Moral absolutism, Thinking
you're right is the right is a
huge blind spot.
Stops us listening.
Stops us understanding.
And conflicts, often not polite
debates but existential clashes,
deep worldviews colliding, built
up over time, each with mythic
power for its followers.
Right.
And this deep dive, it wasn't
about telling you what to think
or taking sides on any issue.
No, definitely not.
Our goal was to offer a
framework based on the source
material to help understand why
people believe what they
believe, why conflict seem so
stuck, and why your own strong
beliefs, while precious, are
rarely universal.
It's about appreciation, the
complex dance of human
conviction stories and the messy
reality of how societies
actually shift or dig in their
heels.
Which leaves us with a final
maybe provocative.
Thought yeah, this raises an
important question.
In a world where righteousness
is so subjective, where
agreement is so rare, and
conflicts are driven by these
deep existential stakes, what's
our real measure of progress or
understanding?
How do we even define common
ground or success when the very
idea of right and wrong is so
fiercely contested and felt so
differently by different groups?
Something to chew on,
definitely.
Something to think about as you
navigate that fascinating, often
clashing terrain of the real
world.
We really hope this deep dive
helps you see it all with
perhaps some new eyes, and maybe
approach things a bit more
strategically with a bit more
understanding of the whole
picture.